so mögen ja dem original so topia heißt
und dieser titel ist ja viel besser es
geht um die utopie und nicht um eine
form von wahnsinn wenn auch form von
wahnsinn eine rolle spielen ist die
geschichte einer stadt in der alle
möglichen tierarten miteinander
auskommen müssen und wollen
und insofern einen schlag in die
magengrube von leuten die es ja
angeblich geben sollen
die behaupten dass ein zivilisiertes
modernes gemeinwesen irgendwie darauf
angewiesen wäre dass die leute ethnisch
oder in sonst irgendeiner form homogen
sind das sind sie da überhaupt nicht die
helden ist eine häsin die zunächst mal
aus quoten gründen zur polizei darf
damit er auch kuscheltiere sind sonst
hinter nashörner und tiger und andere
großkatzen ein paar neue rekruten die
ich vorstellen sollte und sie wird erst
mal auf streife geschickt und lernten
fuchs kennen und stolpert über den
schlimmsten und größten kriminalfall
teams in dieser stadt je gegeben dass
ich weiß wessen auto das ist nicht die
preis gefürchteten gangster aus der
stadt man nennt ihn mister weg und er
mag mich nicht besonders also nichts wie
weg
wir können nicht abhauen und es wird
noch ein viel krassere tatort -ermittler
wirklich hier findet darin verschwinden
sofort erfüllen und deshalb so großartig
weil man sich darin vorkommt wie in
einem der klassischen jump & run
computerspiele
die vorurteile die missverständnisse die
sachen die man somit bringt über das
zusammenleben und darüber wie die leute
miteinander auskommen können oder nicht
die stehen sozusagen ständig im weg
während die handle sich schon weiter
entwickelt also um von oben kommt ein
vorurteil zack von unten kommt
missverständnis und man fiebert teils
wie dem fuchs und hase mit ob sie
dadurch kommen sie kommen dadurch aber
nicht ganz unbeschadet und es ist vor
allen dingen nicht ein pädagogisches
teil in dem irgendwie nur auf gute
nachbarschaft und brüderlichkeit und
sowas gesetzt wird sondern schon auch
auf zähne fletschen und knurren und
allerdings auch sehr viel schnuppern
kinder sollten ihre eltern mitnehmen in
diesem film weil eltern in diesem film
lernen können dass kinder schon wissen
nämlich dass sie vieles nicht kennen die
themen um die es geht und die im moment
aufgrund diverser wahlkämpfe in
verschiedenen ländern zb dem land oder
film her kommt nämlich amerika und dem
land in dem der film jetzt gezeigt wird
nämlich bei uns eine große rolle spielen
sind eigentlich erwachsenen themen aber
andererseits auch wieder nicht wenn man
jemand auf die spielplätze die haben
echt nein gestimmt
ich muss schon sagen du bist noch
niedlicher als erwartet vermutlich
wissen sie das nicht aber wenn ein
harter einschnitt bezeichnet
ich glaube alle menschen interessieren
sich dafür wie sie mit anderen auskommen
können und die meisten beschäftigen sich
lieber damit wenn es auch etwas zu
lachen gibt und wenn man nicht bezahlt
wird und wenn man nicht erzogen wird
dabei sondern wenn man irgendwie mit
vielen kann wo wir sind
ja in rumänien kann jeder alles sein und
die hier sind eben nackt das ist
ästhetisch hier so rund und elektrisch
und so die musik ist sogar gut papiere
als gazelle funktioniert viel besser als
stabiles nennt ich kann das belieben und
hier